state of nevada is planning to execute a
man his lawyers attorneys even a federal
judge are questioning
a lack of transparency zane floyd killed
four people more than 20 years ago and
today
he appeared virtually from prison in a
federal courtroom
no cameras allowed inside but the
i-team's vanessa murphy was there and
has more on what happened
this used to be albertsons and this is
where zane floyd
walked inside and killed four employees
and
injured another in 1999
now more than 20 years later the state
of nevada
is trying to execute him there's
not a whole lot i can
say to the families that was zane floyd
more than 20 years ago
now while nevada lawmakers are
considering abolishing the death penalty
the state is trying to move forward with
plans to execute floyd
it's not yet final but a date could be
set for early june
the nevada department of corrections or
ndok has released
no details a spokeswoman tells the
i-team
information will be released no less
than seven
days before the execution date floyd's
defense team points out floyd has a
right to know which drugs will be used
to kill him
and lawyers need time to review the plan
the nevada attorney general's office
which
represents endoc argues if the names of
the drugs are released drug companies
may sue to make sure their drugs aren't
used for lethal injection
that's what happened in the case against
scott dozier
the last inmate nevada tried to execute
federal judge richard boulware even
questioned the lack of transparency
thursday
and wants lawyers back in court monday
the head of endoc testified but revealed
no information about the plan
director charles daniels said he takes
his duty to carry out the execution
seriously
and pointed out quote there is no do
over button
end quote i can't take back what i've
done
[Music]
if there was any way i could i would and
judge bulware asked
several questions about why there is so
much secrecy about the plan to execute
floyd
we are potentially four weeks away from
nevada's first
execution in about 15 years with no
information released vanessa murphy 8
news now